hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be going over the decline lines
in the ponziani counter gambit which is
my favorite way to attack
the panzani opening if you're not
familiar with ponziani starts out with
e4
e5 and that f3 knight c6 and then
c3 preparing for the push on d4 to
control the center of the board
black counter attacks this with the
ponziano county gambit and that is with
pawn to f5 now i did another video on
the accepted lines
and that is if the pawn takes here on f4
if you haven't watched that video i will
have a link in the description
below so definitely recommend checking
that video out but in today's video
we're going to be going over what
happens if they
decline so they don't take here they
have a few other options we're going to
be looking at if they come here to
d4 if they play bishop to b5
and then lastly if they play d3 so let's
go ahead and dig into
those variations
the most common of these variations for
white is to continue with
d4 and this is what they're setting up
from the beginning with the c3s to push
forward here on d4 control the center of
the board
black has a couple options i think the
easiest way is just to continue taking
here on e4
and then after they played knight takes
on e5 because
there's no other real good options if
they
you know were to try something like
bishop two g5
uh attacking the queen well we just play
bishop to e7
after the exchange here then they can't
just take with their
knight here on e5 because they're going
to go down
material so that doesn't make a lot of
sense they're probably just going to
take with
their knights here on e5 and then we can
play queen 2 f6 if you've watched the
initial video on the ponziano counter
gamut you see that queen 2 f6 is a
pretty common move for black
and i think this is the easier setup and
we'll look at this position here in a
minute then playing
uh something tricky like d6 because
white has some really good options one
they could just push forward with
d5 and once you have played this
move d6 now all of a sudden you can
bring your bishop to
b5 for whites pinning down the knight to
the king
yes the bishop here on c8 is now
attacking
this f5 square but i feel like black can
get into
some pretty tricky situations even if
white takes here on
f5 maybe black recaptures here but then
bishop to
b5 pinning down the knights maybe play
a6 to attack it but then after the
exchange right here
the pawn structure is all beat up pawn
takes here on e5
black recaptures you can see the queens
come off the board you can see double
pawns here
on the c file for black so definitely
not exactly the position
i would like uh and so for that reason
i do think it's easier just to go ahead
and take instead of playing d6 go ahead
and take with your pawn here on e4
they're probably gonna take with their
knight don't see another option that
they really have
and then to play queen to f6
white has a few options from here
probably the best move just go and take
the knights here on
c6 black can take with their pawn this
opens up for
the dark square bishop it also allows
black to play
d5 and have a pretty good pawn structure
in the center so that's why you would be
taking with your b-pawn here
to c6 and then you know if they ever
tried something queen two
h5 check i can't really do too much
without the knight supporting that
because you could just play g6 and
that's going to stop the
attack now if they decide okay they
don't want to take
with their knight here on uh c6
maybe they play queen to c2
attacking the pawn right here let me
just go ahead and play
a d5 up protecting this we have two
central pawns uh they don't so we're in
a pretty good position
right here the other option might be
bishop to b5
but this is going to be a mistake
because with our pawn is here on d7
then bringing the bishop out and you're
not really pinning down the knight to
anything
we just go ahead and take with our
knight here on e5 after they take with
our pawn
we can take with our queen and they're
going to be down
in material so that's what's going to
happen uh if they play the most natural
move
i'm just taking here knight to e5 we're
just going to bring our queen here
to f6
now that was if they play d4 against the
counter gambit but they could play
something else you know bishop to
a b5 maybe they could try but just as we
looked at in the previous example
if they bring their bishop out and it's
not pinning down the knight
this isn't going to do too much for them
we could take with our pawn right here
let's say they take with their bishop
here
well we could just take their bishop
they could play
knight 2 e5 we could play queen 2 g5
this is attacking both the knight
and this pawn here on a g2 there's no
way for them to really
defend this and this pawn here on e4 is
also a nuisance then we can play knight
to f6 at some point
uh we can eventually get our light
square bishop involvement into the game
castle on the queen side so
just know they don't have a lot of good
options bringing the bishop out here
is not going to do anything so what
other options do they have
in their other video we've already
looked at if they take here we've
already looked at if they play
pawn to d4 then they could play somewhat
defensive
they may have come out the gates
thinking that they're going to push
forward and then when we attack the pawn
here on e4
they get a little timid and play d3
supporting this pawn on e4 because they
really don't want you to take
and attack the knight here on f3
so that is absolutely an option from
here because they're playing timid i
like to be extremely aggressive
so i'm going to be looking to push here
on d5
really looking to control the center of
the board
so let's look at all the options that
they may have from here they could take
our
f pawn from here we're just going to
take back with
our bishop right here and we have lots
of different options depending on where
they go we could play knight to
f6 we could get our dark square bishop
involved into the game get our queen
involved into the game to a lot of
different squares castle on
the queen side but you can see here we
have our two central pawns
they have one central pawn we're not
down upon usually when you play a gambit
you're down
in material here your knight on c6 is
protecting your e5 pawn which is being
attacked right now
so you have a very strong setup and you
are controlling the center of the board
definitely a position i like for black
they could also take our other pawn
so take him right here and attacking the
knight here on
c6 we're gonna have to be doing
something but we can just take it with
our queen that's fine
and if they push forward because how do
they really attack right here black is
controlling the center of the board
if they play c4 then i like just
bringing the queen back here to
f7 you have different options you could
play queen to
d6 the main reason that i like queen to
f7
is because this allows me to get my
light square bishop involved into the
game
castle on the queen side and it frees up
this semi-open d
file so that eventually when your rook
comes here to d8
it can attack this entire foul right
here you can see this pawn is going to
be under attack
for black for a while here so it just
gives you a lot of attacking
lines and so that's why queen to f7 well
it may look like a weird square that you
don't bring your queen to that often
in this opening it does do extremely
well if they don't take one of your
pawns
uh tough to find another move that i
think they would play but maybe queen
two a4
uh once you play that d-pawn as we said
that's going to allow them to pin
down your knights they can't bring their
light scored bishop because they are
blocking it by d3 so d3 definitely not
the best move for them
but queen to a4 this is threatening
knight taking here on e5
so that does definitely pose a threat we
have to deal with but then just queen to
d7
really takes everything out of their
attack
hopefully everyone enjoyed this video on
the decline lines
just don't see too many options these
are the the ones i think you may see the
most here
but definitely wanted to make this video
as i did get requests on the last video
always look at the comments to see what
types of videos you want to see
and there's definitely a lot of people
saying hey love the counter gambit but
do want to see the decline line so thank
you guys so much for watching and
supporting the channel
and i will see you in the next video